as the country starts to reopen many of
us will be packing up the car and
hitting the road or
maybe you want to hop on a bike and hit
the highway jc fernandez is live at red
rock harley-davidson and with some cool
options for you hey j.c
uh-oh what are you doing does it doesn't
this look doesn't look like a natural
fit me
on on a harley i tell you what lindsey
and rocky it just feels cool
sitting on this bike imagine being on
the open road
this is mike he's the general manager of
red rock harley mike what kind of bike
is this
well jc you do look good on that bike
yeah that is a 2021
uh street bob in the uh
white pearl now this is a great would
you call this a beginner's bike or who
would buy this kind of bike
it's an entry-level bike it's just a
really great bike
all around bike to ride around has it's
the lightest soft tail that we have
um great seat height it's a really easy
bike to maneuver let's come down this
way because
this is just a step up bigger engine on
this bike they're so cool looking
yeah this is the 2021 fat bob
billiard red this is one of the best
handling harleys on the market for sure
now come down here because what is this
bike is this like the the cadillac of
harley-davidson this one's like
extreme this is called a road glide
special in snake venom
it's got an awesome paint job it kind of
changes colors depending on which angle
you're looking at
with the chrome motor it's such a great
looking bike super popular this year so
now you guys have everything here
your guys are open anyone can come down
here and look at some bikes feeling
being inside red rock harley
real quick i do want to showcase we have
our model here and this is some of the
safety gear that you guys sell here
talk to me about the helmet that she has
well she's got a full face harley helmet
there
it's great protection she's got riding
boots on uh
gloves and uh a jacket that's vented and
everything for riding
um keep safe for a rainy day like this
and actually you guys have classes a
rider's academy coming up in the four
o'clock hour we're gonna tell you all
about the classes and how you can get on
harley this summer
we'll send it back to you guys in the
studio all right jc don't have too much
fun out there
las vegas now will be right